hey reject nation how you doing hi my
idiot army if you're over here real
reject watching everybody on a cleanse
like I am pepper and lemon and you drink
it and they do [ __ ] for days sure yeah
oh that's the best way to been there
done that
I do it once a once a year drop of the
pants drops down subpoenaed all back the
next day when I go to McDonald's well I
don't know if this has to do with that
kind of cleanse there's a Jonathan goal
wiki movie called the cleanse it's a
horror comedy I have no idea what it's
actually about quite a few people have
recommended we watch this ha ha yeah you
know the best to emotions you could
generate in a movie vertical
entertainment okay everybody who's ready
to change their lives today looks like a
pyramid scheme join us well as you try a
brand new program and face your demons
today
[Music]
thank you so much are you being graded
this housing kit each kit contains four
drinks which you must consume by the end
of the day the next stage will be the
elimination process when you say
elimination process you'd be uniquely
[Music]
the cleanse you drank has expelled all
the negativity from your life what and
put it into what you see before you
[Music]
something out of me that's perfectly
normal
what am I supposed to do but that was
that we haven't seen you I know this can
be a scary process you wouldn't believe
what came out don't you I have this
smaller first aah once you finish this
would be a beautiful thing
[Music]
[Music]
we do all have our demons
I like the plot idea I love it I've
heard of that metaphor you know like oh
there's a lot of negative energy and
part of the cleanse you got to expel it
out of you yeah it's not really the
popular belief but I've heard of that
before to take a very literal approach
of that sounds really creepy and fun I
kind of want to do it what if that's
true we thought about that dear
what if that's true if it's true I would
be throwing up unicorns and rainbows
negative energy want to get rid of that
inside you you my unicorn is mean he has
my negative energy but he came out to
look nice like a unicorn so I would be
nice to him I just figure you know I
know you're looking for love and if
you're looking for love maybe you got to
do a cleanse so you can find that look
maybe the goal is you got to get
skinnier than what you are now yeah
that's what I hear all men prefer yeah
real skinny yeah bones get bones skinny
bones is what we're looking for here huh
wiped out all the demons on the inside
as she puked up some bats maybe some
bears of a couple of slugs what else you
got if you want to be attractive you
gotta be willing to throw up what are
you gonna throw up Greg I like gaining
weight and still land like my girlfriend
now she's a thing of beauty yeah you
know what I could gain weight and she'd
still stick around it's true but if
you're gonna do a cleanse you got to
puke out the demon so tell me what your
demons gonna be this is what we're
skipping to here I don't know why you
owe my girlfriend so he thought you
loved me but get big big fat fat skip to
who you got demon to my hair return of
an Eames chair
she's once she gets business a demon has
to come out of you what demon is it
gonna be okay I would throw out a
gremlin thank you very much god I mean
if you would have answered the question
15 minutes ago could have saved us a lot
of time here everybody is asleep already
you remind me so much of my mother and
that's not a pleasant experience your
mother is she has to be pulling out her
hair does she have hair left does she
have any hair left is she completely
bald
no your
right she's balding Rogaine every day
yes I think half the videos I do with
terror is be commenting on the route
Tara takes videos we've been 30 seconds
talking about the actual train trailer
is good I'm gonna go see this movie are
you I am I'm gonna go see it okay I'm
gonna when I sit down and I remember
that video I made with Greg and we watch
this trailer and I talked about mom and
Rogaine and then I'm gonna sit down I'm
gonna haha also at the movie then I'm
also gonna go because that slug he gets
bigger we all saw a little slinky arm oh
it's gonna get scary it's gonna get
scary he's gonna eat people right you
he's gonna open up his mouth this is a
tease because it's trying to make it
look like oh this is kind of like an
adorable weird fairy tale kind of movie
but I bet it's gonna get violent oh yeah
blood everywhere is my kind of thing hey
do you think you'd be posting your
reaction on the Stardust yeah I will I'm
on there too so I'll post my reaction on
the old Stardust app to this movie a
problemo
you got anything else to say to me great
I subscribe click the notification bell
follow tara on youtube click subscribe
to the real rejects he says it under his
breath doesn't and go and subscribe to
me on youtube
it's just a nice tag this city beyond my
idiot army ring the bell are we done
here yeah okay all i was waiting for are
we done yes i'm here doing my job I
don't know what you're doing yeah sure
hit it go ahead I mean you could hit it
a long time ago long time okay okay